what's happening my name is Samuel Leeds
I just arrived here in the Caribbean
islands I'm in St Lucia right now and I
tell you something I'll get messages all
the time from people from the Caribbean
islands saying I really want to get into
property but I've got no money so I
thought as a social experiment I'd come
here with zero money to invest and my
goal is to try and make a hundred
thousand pounds in one day as a social
experiment let's see what we can happen
I got my guide with me somewhere my man
Evans hey I love you what's happening
man
are you amazed
oh man it's amazing this guy's a
property millionaire and he picks me up
in a car like this
dude man so you're going to be my guide
right or tomorrow what's happening
tomorrow bro it's a big day isn't it I'm
getting married he's getting married
tomorrow but today you're supposed to be
getting prepared for the wedding I
should do
but I've robed him into being my guide
for the day he's going to be showing me
around the island so the goal is 100 000
pounds profit in one day I need to find
a deal bro no worries bro where do we
snap where are we going
somewhere with internet connection
another place
[Music]
Saint Lucia
properties
for rent
I'm thinking the obvious strategy is to
do a rent to rent okay yeah yeah and if
we can get that on a three four year
period and make it make 100 Grand over
the turn we'd have to make 100 Grand
today we just have to do a deal that
makes 100 Grand so if I look at
properties for rent here we go look at
this right
Rodney Crescent isn't that like Rodney
Bay it's not like a really nice area
correct so Rodney Bay
you can rent a whole beautiful house
for 920
for an apartment in Rodney Bay
how much would these rent out for if you
did them as service accommodation on a
nightly basis well it depends I mean
Rodney Bay is the help of Tourism for
the nearest award today is the more
expensive but minimum of about 200
pounds all the way up to like two three
grand so that's the perfect rent to rent
yeah look at this man
we need to find some really high-end
stuff I think
[Music]
this is crazy
levels man this property if we wanted to
book it next year
would we be able to book it on a
long-term lease
no like two years
absolutely really yeah
that do it they reckon they'd be open to
a long-term let
me yeah
yeah okay
and you reckon they'll give us a
discount if people get for an entire two
years or so
now that conversation you could have it
with my my money okay
we'll have that conversation then how
much rent do you reckon they'd want a
month for the I mean it's very small
though it's not big it is very small but
it's beautiful though it's Boutique it's
like it really stands out how much do
you reckon they'd accept I'm gonna do
probably once an arm and a leg I think
they'll probably want enough of like
50 Grand
there's no way I'd pay 50 Grand a month
I do like it
if you're paying 50 Grand a month how
much you reckon it would be this would
run out for a night minimum three grand
minimum well we can verify that because
there's loads that it's already yeah so
if you're getting three grand a night
which I will have to verify
that's gonna be three grand a night
times let's say it's fully occupied
which it always is
it's not right now though is it it's
empty so I'm checking in today right
let's say you get three guns times up by
30. yeah
90 grand
it's always filled man
and you can get forget I mean look ask
the guest next door how much did it pay
all right so we're just gonna say to him
it's a simple pitch right yeah we want
to rent it for two years yeah
what's the lowest you could accept or
still live with the thing is if they're
if they're getting like um yes she said
she got me doing that long oh
meeting with Emma if she says yes
we will have a bungalow under our
control
in St Lucia
maybe I don't think 25 is enough I think
she's going to be like
should we just ask a question with
ourselves rather than giving a
a low number what do you think
no because then she'll just say oh wait
should we go tonight I want 90 grand
if we low ball her a bit
and then if she says 20 grand no why
fifth day we'll go okay
even if even at 50 Grand we need to find
out the occupancy as well yeah but I've
been trying to book it
on my phone he says on their website
from three grand
that's insane
that's it three grand a night hello how
are you so what I was thinking is
would you guys be open for us to
essentially rent it on like a long-term
lease
okay you're charging you for a night so
we won't be able to do a monthly okay
well that was awkward
she wouldn't even give us a one percent
discount bruh
she said whatever you do if I have a
long instead it is per night
I don't blame them if they've got 100
occupancy right and they're charging
three grand four grand a night
I want to stay there if we managed to
get a deal that's profitable and comes
off today
I'm gonna go back and say me again how
much do you charge another three again
is it four is it five oh I want to book
three nights and I'm just gonna chill
there for the rest of my time let's go
get a deal man damn
[Music]
okay to the show
you know what personally what I'm
thinking is the rent-to-end business
model Works 100 because the fact that
there's people paying free grand a night
for short stays yeah we need to find a
landlord that's just up for doing the
they've already got all the systems and
processes to rent out short stay let's
we need to find a property that's an
apartment maybe like one of these or
something yeah so like are these
apartments that's that's a hotel
we need to find an apartment block look
it's for sale should we approach them
hold on drive to it drive to it drive to
it no no reverse man back up back up I
go turn around there's a vehicle behind
me man what are you doing it's not
England you know
is it is it for sale
yes I want to see what that says man
now my phone doesn't work so I need I
need I need a Caribbean Sim hold on stop
stop
Landings Resort and Spa for sale
so the whole thing how much is that
going for
okay let's can we ring him on your phone
yeah we can bring them should we ring
them yeah man
what's that happening so this is a
Caribbean phone
do you need a code
come on man you're from you're supposed
to be like my Saint Lucian died with an
English phone
why don't we just go in and speak to
them you're right they're right there
all right park there and we'll go let's
do it thank you Clarence have a good day
man have a good day cheers
just go there bro we're only going to be
in a minute aren't we
don't take us five minutes to get a
lease option agreement secured yeah
there was a sign outside the hotel
saying the hotel was for sale
that's what it says on the side
hello how you doing nice to meet you
um good to meet you good Evan nice to
meet you and you we're just coming in
because we saw outside there was a sign
that says this place is for sale yeah
um we're investors okay I just wondered
do you have a picture yeah yeah that's
okay yeah yeah cool
you're from UK yeah yeah oh cool
whereabouts are you from
yeah no so we're basically uh we're
buying properties and stuff while we're
out here and we're documented it okay um
just because it's not every it's not
every day you come to a Caribbean Island
and start buying stuff
all right mate
this is nice
that one
yeah
mate this is amazing
absolutely amazing
so how many bedrooms is this one Simon
bedroom two bedroom
yep
is there a restriction in the headlines
so that we couldn't rent it out on Short
Stay lets or anything we can't do that
because we're running a hotel as well
you rent it to your friend on Airbnb he
comes here and the light's not working
that's your problem hotels
and say this is not working that's not
working basically you haven't looked up
sure
so what you're saying is
what you're saying is we could buy it at
a good price and then we could give it
to the hotel and they would manage it
[Music]
land for sale
yeah yeah
sugar my Thomas
this this area feels a little bit poorer
though bro
it's poorer I can't lie no no there's
loads of grand provisions and banana
trees it's a very rich okay I just
bought a property
in a slum but don't worry because
there's a banana tray be very careful
guys right this is a very busy road land
for sale that view does not sell this is
where you grow up it's not very flat is
it
the good thing about this light here you
won't have any issue getting planning
like it's very simple the problem is
like the houses around the area
they're just like Shacks bro
so if you build a house here how
expensive
but what's going to be the end value of
a house that you
it's like the opposite if you know those
Bungalows yeah
how much those bungos gonna cost to
build
maximum 20 25k right they're freaking
Bungalows bro wooden Bungalows peanuts
yeah right how much is the value of
those bungalows a lot why locations sea
views why commercial valuation I think
what we need to do is I think we need to
hit everyone that owns land right near
the sea where it could potentially be a
tourist and go do it so there's no
estate agents at all around this area
what we need is what tourists want
tourists want the sea mountains Beach so
I'm desperately trying to find land
online around the sea around the beaches
around the mountains build a sheep house
little Log Cabin Bank you got your money
then commercial valuations rents
that's the strategy but we haven't got
long the sun is beginning to set we need
to get in Lander viewings now
let's find a problem at all for the game
today or not
connect can I view today
oh
no all right
good all right that's the final part of
it so that's fine thank you thank you so
much have a good day I'm getting Evans
to speak on the phone because my English
accent that might add an extra zero on
the price of the land you know what I'm
saying so
keep on going man let's get these
viewings
foreign
[Music]
but it's noticy yeah but from where it
is it's like is anyone living here
surely not it looks derelict it looks
derelict
so here's a question man like what I
would typically want to do with a house
like this is clearly derelict it does
are those doors even real look they've
been painted ombre
what I'll be thinking
with this type of house
I know how I can make 100 Grand on this
house
I know exactly how I make 100 from this
house with no money I think I know what
you're thinking go on I think you can
just split it split the flats oh
oh
come on come on let's go
on the house
that is a strange hat you know what
I thought there was no elimination
derelict I was thinking assisted sale
okay let's say we say to them how much
you want for that 50 Grand it's crap
it's run down
we'll do it on assisted sale
we then get a loan refurb the house push
the value up then sell it for 300 or
whatever it is and then the profit we
keep 100 grand
but
I don't know how to find out who owns it
you're my guide supposed to be helping
me
yeah should we try the neighbors
yeah well where are they're on the
neighbors bro there's a yellow house
here who's this
yeah
oh it's our next viewing yeah that's the
next year yeah no dogs
hopefully
hello how are you nice to meet you
Samuel to meet you nice to meet you you
know what every five minutes the Evans
kept pulling over for another KFC that's
not true
do you need to lift with us do you need
a lift with us yes yeah I was just
calling ashant to say to him
let's have a look yeah that's fine you
jump in the front I'll squeeze in the
back with the girls
yeah
maybe about 20 minutes okay
all right let's go
Evans drives nicely can you
can you see we're gonna go up here we'll
look at it from Ohio
vantage point
so who owns this land here that we're
standing on
oh you own this land and who is this
your house
okay hi
wow breathtaking views yes
so St Vincent's that way Barbados is
that way yes and Saint Thomas is maybe
that way I'm still trying to get my
geography but beautiful Martinique is to
the north of the island okay there's a
beach
there's another Beach here oh wow
actually on the tip of the island
because
because we have a fish
tea so that's that's the tale of the
Island right here
amazing yes yes so because our property
goes across the fish state so the fish
steer is down there so from from a
planning point of view do you reckon
we'll get planning to build on it yeah
not a problem because we got planning
for that side
thank you
oh my gosh literally
Ocean View Every Which Way walking
distance from the beach
and the lady she has had the land for
years doesn't have the money to develop
it
perfectly on this side you're only on
this side
when did you buy the land
my parents did okay so you just
inherited it
how long have you wanted to develop it
for
[Music]
yeah
what's been what's been holding you back
why did you not
anything yeah
yeah you know you have things set in
your mind but to actualize it
it needs the funds yeah and you need
somebody
who has the knowledge and who is capable
of doing it who is trustworthy who can
do it with you and that has been
a difficult thing yeah so does your line
go all the way down to the sea or not it
borders the beach
so could you walk to the beach yeah
yeah there is there's a truck right here
then you can take a walk to the beach
because then people had some of the best
beaches you know what though that would
work so good for um short stylets
because people love to be able to have
sea views walk the beach yeah yeah so
for you it's just mainly the finance the
experience the effort the all that stuff
and to get those things through planning
I don't have a problem in assisting you
yeah okay so basically in principle then
for you to basically provide the land
and then we just split everything all of
the profits
50 50.
good
lovely to meet you good
I'm excited
here's a question then right if you used
to work in a bank yeah can you not get
development Finance to build
the price is too heavy they'll charge
you a fortune
the chart isn't too high yeah
yeah
so tell us what you do and tell us what
your business is and what your
connection to Urban's is
okay what are the construction like
General Construction
again everything like from start to
finish
so you build things from scratch right
this
type of construction yeah
you can see it's like a nice wooden
cabin how much do you think it would
cost from start to finish to build that
from scratch okay
I would say 250 square foot we don't
know what 250 um easy dollars yeah so
how much 42 000
42 000 is that US dollars
PC right to do it nice yeah yeah okay
just just the just the like we said just
the structure right so what about
including the toilets and the island
kitchen that's that's where the prices
change
yeah yeah so we could put let's put
another another twenty thousand
so in pounds
about like 600 times
you still fighting the house about 35
Grand
in total for everything including the
toilet it's never done
I mean do you reckon you'd be able to do
us a little bit of a deal
if we were to
you know do something together we could
even get you involved what are your
thoughts
so what what what evidence what are you
obviously you guys are brothers I don't
want to overstep the mark but what are
you thinking Evans
we were thinking obviously if you can
obviously go on and do the build for us
rather than paying you
if you could have potentially
you know fund the materials up front do
the labor and we give you a bit more of
them
how does that sound
make a pattern please repeat
I think he's asking whether whether you
could potentially
fund it and then we could pay you more
but down the line the underlying as hell
when it's completely how far down the
line yeah that's a nice question well
what we could do is you know when we're
renting it and we're making a lot of
profit from it we could pay you we could
negotiate something but
but what are you you guys are brothers
man so
but what would you need as interest in
order to make it viable like 10 percent
I like it she's beautiful numbers yeah
yeah yeah so if we gave you one percent
a month interest until you're paid off
something like that could work
[Music]
my brother yeah are you happy to help
out your bro why not anyway you're
willing yeah yeah good give him a cuddle
then
business partners I'm just dropping
Evans back at his house but in one day
with Evan's help I managed to find a
landowner securing no money down joint
venture partnership managed to get a
builder who agreed to do a no money down
development where we pay him out the
profits down the line so I'm putting
down nothing no money
he's going to make at least hundred
grand of course I have to give 50 to my
joint venture partner but I'm left with
50 grand and I'm over the moon right now
the opportunities in Caribbean is crazy
when my 50 Grand actually hits the bank
once it's all done because it will take
time
I'm gonna give 25 Grand half of it to my
boy Evans Evans big respect bro and his
hand bro you excited about your wedding
tomorrow I'm super pumped what do you
think about the market you think I
should move bro you and I will kill this
I'm loving Caribbean man anytime bro I
can't wait man take any respect thank
you man great guy yeah come on
[Music]
foreign